si tienen un medio y lo perturban crean
una onda en un medio que no tiene
límites es decir el medio es tan grande
que básicamente esta onda nunca llega a
los límites cuando esto pasa nada nos
puede detener para crear una onda de
cualquier longitud de onda o frecuencia
que se nos ocurra en otras palabras no
hay una longitud de onda natural
preferida todas las longitudes de onda
son igual de buenas entre sí sin embargo
si combinamos esta onda en un medio que
tiene límites
esta onda se va a reflejar cuando llegue
al límite lo que quiere decir que se va
a superponer oa traslapar en sí misma y
cuando esto sucede creamos algo llamado
ondas estacionarias y en un minuto
explicaremos qué significan las ondas
estacionarias nos interesan porque
cuando ocurren eligen longitudes de onda
preferidas y frecuencias solo longitudes
de onda y frecuencias van a configurar
estas ondas estacionarias
lares y lo que ocurre con frecuencia es
que éstas se vuelven dominantes y es por
eso que es importante estudiar estas
ondas estacionarias y para estudiarlas
vamos a tomar un ejemplo en particular
digamos que tienen una cuerda y van a
clavar ambos extremos de esta cuerda de
manera que no ocurra movimiento alguno
en los extremos de esta cuerda esta
cuerda se puede mover en el medio pero
no se puede mover en los extremos y esto
no es muy extraño las cuerdas de una
guitarra están sujetas en los extremos
lo mismo que las cuerdas en un piano así
que la física detrás de las ondas
estacionarias determinan el tipo de nota
que vamos a obtener en estos
instrumentos por cierto en estos
extremos lo que estamos haciendo es
evitar que haya movimiento aquí no hay
movimiento es lo que sucede cuando lo
clavamos en este extremo no va a haber
movimiento alguno y tampoco habrá
movimiento en este otro extremo
en lugar de llamar a estos puntos puntos
donde no hay movimiento a los físicos se
les ocurrió un nombre en particular
llaman a estos puntos nodos así que no
do es una palabra sofisticada para
indicar que en este punto no hay
movimiento así que para esta cuerda
tendremos nodos en cada extremo y
veremos que cuando tenemos una onda
estacionaria es posible tener nodos en
el medio de la cuerda pero no tiene por
qué ser así pero en esta cuerda nos
vamos a asegurar de que no haya
movimiento en los extremos es decir que
haya un nodo en cada extremo de ella y
por qué y cómo es que ocurre en las
ondas estacionarias digamos que le damos
un pequeño tirón a la cuerda en este
extremo y debido a la perturbación ésta
se va a estar moviendo a través de esta
línea ya que es lo que hacen las
perturbaciones va a llegar aquí y una
vez que alcanza el límite se va a
reflejar
hacia la izquierda y resulta que cuando
una perturbación llega a un límite que
está fijo es decir cuando llega a un
nodo se va a invertir quizá esto ya lo
hayan visto en las mangueras mandan un
pulso sobre la línea y quieren ver cómo
se refleja se va a reflejar de cabeza no
importa mucho para nuestros propósitos
pero cada vez que se refleja un pulso
cambiará su dirección y va a rebotar
ahora digamos que en lugar de enviar un
solo pulso enviamos varios pulsos
consecutivos enviamos una onda de
movimiento armónico simple y ahora
cuando esto se refleje se va a reflejar
sobre sí misma ya que este frente de
onda se va a reflejar invertido hacia
esta dirección y se va a encontrar con
el resto de la onda que viene detrás
suyo y se va a superponer en esta o
atrás la pared está creando una onda
total que estará compuesta por la onda
que viaja hacia la derecha más
onda que viaja hacia la izquierda y
pueden usar interferencia y
superposición para calcular cuál será la
onda total y para la mayor parte de las
longitudes de onda esto va a ser un
desastre pueden enviar cualquier
longitud de onda que quieran y cuando se
refleje sobre sí misma la onda total que
obtendremos podría no ser algo especial
podemos tener algo raro aquí nada
realmente interesante
sin embargo habrá longitudes de onda
particulares que provoquen ondas
estacionarias y se las voy a mostrar en
un momento como encontramos estas
longitudes de onda particulares pues
simplemente nos preguntamos cuáles
longitudes de onda puedo dibujar en esta
cuerda para que exista un nodo en cada
extremo quien longitud de onda podría
caber en esta región y que tenga un nodo
en cada extremo así que en lugar de
sumar
complicadas podemos encontrar estas
longitudes de onda especiales
simplemente dibujando las y ver cuáles
caben vamos a hacerlo quitemos todo esto
en longitudes de onda caben aquí pues
sabemos cómo luce una onda armónica
simple se ve así y le pregunta que
debemos hacernos es que si comenzamos en
el punto cero ya que quiero asegurarme
de tener un nodo en el extremo izquierdo
como se verá la forma de esta gráfica de
manera que tenga otro nodo a la derecha
también una posibilidad es vean aquí
inicio en un nodo cuál es el siguiente
nodo que me encuentro pues me encuentro
un nodo cuando tengo esta forma así que
una posibilidad que será la posibilidad
más larga y más grande será una onda que
luzca así algo así como una cuerda para
saltar la primera onda estacionaria que
podemos configurar en esta cuerda es
y es tan especial que le llamamos la
longitud de onda fundamental esta es la
principal ya que domina a todas las
otras longitudes de onda que vamos a ver
y aunque hay otras ondas estacionarias
que podemos configurar aquí esta es la
principal si dejamos que esta cuerda
vibre como quiera esta va a elegir la
longitud de onda fundamental y que
veremos pues la onda no se va a mantener
suspendida en el aire como aquí se va a
estar moviendo y a estas les llamamos
ondas estacionarias porque este pico no
va a aparecer que se esté moviendo hacia
la derecha o hacia la izquierda este
pico se va a estar moviendo arriba y
abajo por eso muchas veces cuando
dibujamos estas ondas estacionarias
dibujamos una línea punteada por abajo
que es un reflejo de la línea completa
ya que lo único que van a hacer estos
picos es ir de arriba a abajo luego de
abajo arriba y así sucesivamente y solo
van a oscilar casi como una cuerda de
saltar solo que no van a estar dando
vueltas
se van a mover de arriba a abajo y que
ya no tengan esta forma quizás se vean
más planetas como esta de aquí y luego
llegue así y luego suban y así siga
yendo de arriba hacia abajo y quizá más
que estacionarias serían ondas
bailarinas pero las llamamos ondas
estacionarias porque estos picos no se
mueven ni a la derecha ni a la izquierda
así que esta es la longitud de onda
fundamental cuál es la que sigue bueno
sabemos que tenemos que ir de un nodo al
siguiente así que aquí partimos de un
nodo nos encontramos con el siguiente
nodo continuamos y nos encontramos con
otro nodo y esta es la siguiente onda
estacionaria posible ya que tiene que
caber aquí cómo se vería iría hacia
arriba luego hacia abajo y de nuevo
hacia arriba encontrándose con el nodo
en el otro extremo esta es la segunda
onda estacionaria a veces también
llamada segunda armónica segunda porque
es la segunda posibilidad y es armónica
porque éstas son resonancias las
cuáles se usan mucho cuando hablamos de
instrumentos musicales cómo se verá la
tercera armónica
veamos comenzamos en un nodo llegamos a
este y esta es la onda estacionaria
fundamental después llegamos a la
segunda armónica y la que sigue será la
tercera armónica así que ésta va hacia
arriba luego baja luego vuelve a subir y
finalmente vuelve a bajar hasta el otro
nodo esta es la tercera armónica y
pueden continuar de esta manera aquí
pueden encontrar una cantidad infinita
de armónicas pero vamos a analizar qué
es lo que sucede aquí arriba que es lo
que pasa en estas ondas estacionarias
vean que vamos a tener puntos como en
esta tercera armónica en la que voy a
dibujar su reflejo es así como se vería
después de cierto tiempo de hecho se
vería así a la mitad del periodo de la
onda con la línea completa así que este
pico se va a mover aquí abajo este valle
se mueve hacia
pico este pico se mueve aquí abajo y van
a estar oscilando de arriba hacia abajo
pero vean que este punto de aquí se
queda quieto no se mueve para nada por
lo que es un nodo lo mismo ocurre en
este otro punto estos puntos ocurren
porque cuando la onda rebota recuerden
que esta onda está viajando en la cuerda
hacia la derecha y va a rebotar hacia la
izquierda y en estos dos puntos de aquí
tendremos interferencia destructiva
entre estas dos ondas de forma similar
en estos puntos en donde tenemos el
máximo desplazamiento las dos ondas se
alinean de tal manera que tienen una
interferencia constructiva por lo que
los nodos es donde tenemos interferencia
destructiva en donde estas ondas se
cancelan lo cual tiene sentido porque
nada está ocurriendo aquí un día que no
hay movimiento y en estos puntos de
máximo desplazamiento son los puntos
constructivos a los cuales deberíamos
darles un nombre
como creen que se deben de llamar sí
dijeron anti nodos están en lo correcto
a estos se les llama anti nodos ya que
es aquí en donde hay el mayor movimiento
y muchas veces ustedes tienen que
encontrar matemáticamente en términos de
la longitud de la cuerda cuáles son las
longitudes de onda que podemos tener
aunque el dibujar las ondas nos ayuda
como los podemos obtener matemáticamente
bueno aquí tenemos un desastre vamos a
limpiarlo quitamos esto y ponemos varias
cuerdas y no vamos a hacerlo muy
abstracto digamos que la longitud de
esta cuerda es bastante grande digamos
que es de unos 10 metros es una cuerda
grande que está asegurada en ambos
extremos la primera onda estacionaria
luce así como una cuerda para saltar
ahora si la cuerda tiene una longitud de
10 metros cuál será la longitud de onda
esta onda quizás ustedes me podrían
decir ah pues es de 10 metros pero no
aquí no tenemos una longitud de onda
completa vean este patrón de onda que
tenemos aquí esto de aquí es una
longitud de onda completa tiene que
llegar hasta aquí esto de acá es sólo la
mitad de la longitud de onda así que
esta cuerda para saltar es sólo la mitad
de la longitud de la onda para ver la
longitud de onda completa tendríamos que
extenderla todo esto hasta acá ésta
sería una longitud de onda completa es
decir serían 10 metros más otros 10
metros por lo que la longitud de onda de
esto aún cuando no quepa en esta cuerda
si pudiéramos ver una longitud de onda
completa aquí esta longitud de onda
sería de 20 metros
cuál es la siguiente onda estacionaria
recuerden que se veía así subía luego
pasaba por el medio hacia abajo y volvía
a subir y aunque esta onda fundamental
no tenía ningún modo
en el medio está segunda onda si tiene
un nodo a la mitad y nuevamente si esta
cuerda mide 10 metros cuál será esta
longitud de onda es fácil esta es una
longitud de onda completa por lo que
medirá 10 metros esta longitud de onda
es de 10 metros ya que la longitud de
onda completa cabe aquí y la tercera
armónica se ve así tiene dos nodos en el
medio seguimos agregando un nodo en el
medio tenemos nuestra onda fundamental
sino dos en el medio la segunda armónica
tiene un nodo en el medio la tercera
armónica tiene dos la cuarta tendría
tres y así sucesivamente
así que cuanto mide esta longitud de
onda este es un poquito más difícil de
encontrar
así que analicemos la tenemos una
longitud de onda completa hasta aquí por
lo que esto es una longitud de onda pero
nuestra cuerda tiene esta longitud por
lo que cuál fracción de esta cuerda
equivale a esta longitud de onda
de dos tercios de la longitud total por
lo que podemos decir que esta longitud
de onda es dos tercios de 10 metros que
podemos escribirlo como 20 metros entre
3 y vamos a seguir encontrando las
siguientes ondas estacionarias esta es
la cuarta armónica cuál es la longitud
de esta longitud de onda pues esta
longitud de onda abarca la mitad de la
cuerda de la mitad de 10 es 5 metros y
podemos continuar podría dibujar la
quinta armónica que se vería así y
tienen que preguntarse qué tan larga es
esta longitud de onda
pues en este caso tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 5 de
estas curvas por lo que esta longitud de
onda va a medir dos quintas partes de la
longitud de la cuerda por lo que esta
lambda va a ser igual a 2 por 10 es 20
metros entre 52 quintos de 10 va a ser
20 metros entre 5 que podemos
simplificar a 4 metros pero qué pasaría
si nos preguntaran cuál es la longitud
de onda de la armónica 43 chispas pues
la verdad no me quiero poner a dibujar
43 ondas aquí para tratar de encontrar
cuál fracción de la cuerda es una
longitud de onda y no tenemos que
hacerlo aquí hay un patrón y se los voy
a mostrar esto se ve medio extraño pero
voy a escribir esta onda fundamental
como 2 por 10 metros entre 1 y la
segunda armónica la voy a escribir como
2 por 10 metros entre 2 y la tercera
armónica la voy a escribir como
por 10 metros entre 3
la cuarta armónica la voy a escribir
como dos por diez metros entre cuatro de
la misma forma la quinta armónica se
puede escribir como dos por diez metros
entre cinco ya que es veinte quintos y
ahora yo espero que puedan ver el patrón
si yo quiero la longitud de onda de la
enésima armónica la n puede ser la
primera la segunda la tercera por lo que
en él puede ser cualquier entero desde
123 etcétera y puedo encontrar la
longitud de onda que va a tener
simplemente calculando 2 por la longitud
de la cuerda que voy a expresar como l
mayúscula para que pueda aplicar a
cualquier cuerda de cualquier longitud
siempre y cuando tenga nodos en los
extremos es 2 por l y lo dividimos entre
m en otras palabras si yo quiero
encontrar la longitud de onda de la
armónica número 84 voy a multiplicar 2
por la longitud de ésta
y lo voy a dividir entre 84 si quiero la
longitud de la armónica número 33
voy a multiplicar 2 por la longitud de
onda de la cuerda y lo voy a dividir
entre 33 y esto me dará la longitud de
onda de dicha armónica ahora recuerden
que cuando deducimos esta ecuación
dibujamos estas imágenes y supusimos que
estos extremos no se mueven tenemos
nodos a cada extremo de la cuerda lo que
casi siempre es el caso porque la
mayoría de los instrumentos tienen
cuerdas que están sujetas en los
extremos en resumen cuando cocinamos una
onda en cierta región la onda se va a
reflejar al llegar a un extremo y se va
a trasladar consigo misma lo que va a
ocasionar interferencia constructiva y
destructiva para longitudes de onda
particulares podemos tener ondas
estacionarias lo que significa que la
onda solo va a oscilar de arriba hacia
abajo en lugar de moverse de izquierda a
derecha
en estas ondas estacionarias a los
puntos en donde no hay movimiento les
vamos a llamar nodos y a los puntos en
donde tenemos el mayor desplazamiento
nos vamos a llamar anti nodos podemos
encontrar las longitudes de onda de las
ondas estacionarias posibles en una
cuerda que esté fija en ambos extremos
al asegurarnos de que la onda
estacionaria tome la forma de una onda
armónica simple con nodos en ambos
extremos que si lo tenemos así vamos a
poder usar una fórmula para encontrar
las longitudes de ondas posibles para
una onda estacionaria de nodo a nodo que
es de dos veces el largo de la cuerda
dividida entre el número de la armónica
que nos interesa